joining me now Jim trust the attorney
for president Trump and former Federal
prosecutor Jim
um thank you for joining us tonight uh
what can you tell us about the charges
as you know them
well we don't have the actual indictment
yet I suppose they'll give that to us at
some point between now and Tuesday
afternoon maybe they're too embarrassed
to give it to us early I don't know but
it's a combination of theoretical
charges again we just have a summary we
don't have the indictment in front of us
but it looks like the Espionage Act
which is kind of laughable on its face
several types of obstruction and
conspiracy and then false statements so
they're kind of throwing everything in
the kitchen sink up on the wall in an
investigation that even in just recent
days we have brought to light criminal
obstruction
Behavior by the investigators you know
it's it's an amazing moment Laura I have
not built a career attacking doj I was a
prosecutor for 27 years I spent 17 years
there loved it but this is outrageous
that they actually have prosecutors who
literally among other things we've
categorized a number of abuses literally
told an attorney that he probably won't
get his judge up if he doesn't flip his
guy against the president you know you
don't have to be a lawyer to recognize
there's something really wrong with that
one of their main investigators one of
their main prosecutors I should say said
that in front of five others who kind of
looked down at their shoes and didn't
say anything basically committing a
federal crime at the Department of
Justice to try to to bring home
cooperation from who they viewed as an
important witness it is astounding that
that's not the real headline as opposed
to this indictment well NBC News justice
correspondent Jim says that
Trump doesn't have a defense in that
this legal strategy
that he has I guess that you're leading
will just focus on discrediting the doj
watch this
Trump's lawyers are really not keen on
arguing the facts here or the law and
are arguing that their client is is not
guilty of these potential charges but
they're more concerned with arguing
about how the doj played Hardball and
look they did play hardball in this case
and we'll just have to see whether the
justice department did anything wrong in
the process of Prosecuting this case
Jim the argument that you won't actually
argue the charges you're just going to
argue the reputation of the department
itself
no I mean look this was basically trying
to appeal to somebody in that chain that
praetorian guard for the Democratic
party to have a conscience you know the
Attorney General is hiding behind the
special counsel he still controls
special counsel but he sat there and hid
didn't want to meet with us didn't want
to talk didn't want to consider the
ethical problems we raised it quietly at
first loudly now that their
investigation is fatally flawed from
outrageous misconduct perhaps even
criminal misconduct but make no mistake
I mean there are layers of defenses to
these charges and the most fundamental
thing just so your viewers get this
Laura there's this thing called the
presidential records act it is precisely
dealing with presidents and former
presidents and basically saying and doj
agreed with this years ago in a case
involving Bill Clinton that the former
president gets to decide what he keeps
he should work really closely with
archives they can ask him nicely if they
get mad they think he's holding on to
too many things they have a remedy
called civil suits there is no criminal
penalty for violating the presidential
records act it's a reflection of the
fact that historically before Nixon they
had completely unfettered rights to keep
everything now we're saying at least
please work with archives so we can see
some of the stuff you created while
you're in the white house so that was
the starting point and by the way Lord
one quick point on this sure the
referral from the National Archives to
doj came from the White House actually
violating the administrative procedures
act and they lied about this they're the
ones that started this thing the the
politicized bureaucrats at Nara the
archivists were happy to push it forward
and into this praetorian guard of doj
who's hell-bent on Prosecuting them no
matter how many rules they break one of
the one of the claims I believe one of
the accounts will involve a potential
obstruction of justice which as you know
in my old career as a as a white-collar
criminal defense attorney Jim was always
considered very seriously along with
conspiracy accounts which perhaps will
be involved in this indictment as well
listed in the indictment the the concern
that is raised that if if the president
was told not to move boxes and they have
someone on video indeed moving boxes
even if there was nothing in the boxes
those particular boss boxes that that
could be a problem or if tape recordings
exist that where someone tells someone
move that that's where people get into
trouble How concerned about that are you
tonight
yeah not well look not not as much as
you might think because if you really
know the facts and I can't play out all
the facts on TV but if you really know
the facts there's absolutely no intent
there there's nothing to make sense in
fact you can't even obstruct a non-crime
as a starting principle so when you have
the presidential record act defense when
you have declassification as a defense
then there's really nothing I mean he
could have had a party throwing stuff in
a bonfire and it wouldn't be obstruction
but the reality is these guys have been
desperately grasping for an obstruction
theory for a political reason which is
they keep trying to set up this oh Joe
Biden's wonderful holding on to stuff
that he stole from a skiff in 1974 but
Trump just didn't answer the Bell well
the last thing the president said to doj
to that same guy who extorted a lawyer
was if you need anything just ask he
told his lawyer at the time show them
where the stuff is kept in the storage
room and they did that and so he says
just let us know the next thing he gets
is a letter that says please put a lock
on the door which he does and then doj
goes by black because that prosecutor
was desperate to get a search warrant
even before he had ever met the
president he had even the Washington
Post reports that that prosecutor before
they even did a subpoena was saying how
do I get the nose Under the Tent at
Mar-A-Lago or words to that effect so
that's what happened they dropped off a
cliff because they didn't want to
cooperate with President Trump's lawyer
the president was cooperative through
and through the lawyer would have been
but they went radio black until they
show up in their khakis with their
laptops and their guns and their Badges
and they do an unprecedented raid with
really a general warrant that violates
the Fourth Amendment but we'll do a
separate show on that some other time uh
Jim do you think that if president Trump
this is a rhetorical question had
said last year recently now I'm actually
not running for president I'm not gonna
I'm not going to be involved in the 2024
campaign I'm retiring from politics
How likely would it have been that they
would have gone after him
well zero percent the fervor would have
dropped
point five percent how about that you
know really hard to figure out what does
that mean that's less than one right
yeah yeah so a really small percentage
the only way I mean look there is abject
hatred for president Trump in some of
the circles of doj and the FBI so uh you
know he he could have basically like
saved an orphanage from a fire and these
guys would say he's lucky and they'd
still go after him the other thing that
kind of that I think affects that whole
equation is that Delaware we're
apparently all investigations go to die
in Delaware you've got horrific
family-wide corruption foreign
corruption scandals involving the Biden
family as well as the laptop from hell
and they're and they're slow walking the
heck out of that so you know that's
always cover for whatever soft deal they
want to give Hunter to do something
against President Trump say look how
balanced we are we we softened a little
misdemeanor tax plea for Hunter and we
also indicted a president for something
that's not criminal that's that's
facially absurd now on the New York
Times just reported tonight Jim that one
of the charges is in fact a violation of
the Espionage Act now your reaction to
that if that is indeed the case
yeah I mean look they're dusting off
stuff that uh you know across the board
was apparently not in play when when
Hillary uh you know bleach bidded 30 000
emails that were under subpoena but the
Espionage Act includes a whole bunch of
language that not just that the
documents implicate National Defense uh
but that your intent is to violate the
sovereignty of the United States to hurt
the United States or to help a foreign
power that's absurd under any theory of
this case and they've got a whole bunch
of rotating theories because they can't
find the facts they want but there's
absolutely nothing remotely like that
you know if he holds on to some
documents or people pack documents and
he has them in the storage room uh even
if he talks about those documents or
talks about the existence of them that
is light years away from the from the
specific intent that they need for an
Espionage case Jim what's the
president's mood tonight I know he knew
this was coming but give us a sense of
what the man's feeling tonight
um you know it's it's an interesting mix
Laura you know people think that uh that
you know when you're accused of
something it's pretty natural at least
from my client base to really turn
inward right you know you're like what
the heck how is this happening it's a
particularly hard moment when you're
innocent and he's actually innocent you
know it's a little easier when you've
done something wrong and you go ah crap
they finally caught up with me that's
not what we're talking about so there is
that kind of initial shock I think he's
got a lot of people around him
expressing support and that's a mixed
bag it kind of puts it in your head as a
very depressing notion but he also
doesn't lose track of the absolute
crossing of the Rubicon as a country you
know the historic nature of a sitting
president unleashing the hounds to go
after a non-criminal event to basically
incapacitate the opposition it is an
astounding third world moment and again
that's not my shtick as an attorney to
go around saying that in cases but
that's where we are as a country and you
know the other people that are
celebrating tonight better realizing
they're letting something out of the
Genie bottle that's going to hurt this
country for Generations well and the
investigations can be turned on them and
will be turned on them if this is
allowed to stand Jim we appreciate it
obviously we're covering covering every
aspect of this thank you very much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else